est ce que vous voyez la tête du mec qui
s'est couché à 5 heures du matin et qui
a passé des heures sur le montage je
suis le plus heureux du monde ce matin
si vous avez regardé la vidéo d'hier je
l'étais directement chez mes potes de
radio scoop et que vois-je ce matin sur
facebook et sur twitter
d re tweetent départage des night décidé
ça sur le compte officiel de radio sco
sur twitter sur facebook on a même parlé
hier de la maxe radio vous connaissez
max quittes et l'animateur star les
normes animateur star créé les vocations
à tous les animateurs actuels même
guillaume pley on peut le dire a
franchement pompe et max qui étaient les
normes animateur de fun radio
à la fin des années 80 et la fin des
années 90 et au début des années 2000 eh
ben on en parlait hier parce
qu'effectivement chez ce couple et
écouter la maxe radio pascal a gentiment
envoyé un message à max pour l'avertir
collectivement parler de lui et qu'est
ce qu'il est dit max et ben il a dit que
c'était cool donc pour ça on est un
grand pousse donc merci radio scoop
merci à pascal merci à tous les amis je
suis vraiment le plus heureux du monde
ce matin et j'espère que ça va continuer
comme ça
[Musique]
on est où là
lukaku on est au cacao et on est parti
voir qui allait voir cleanequity olaf un
gros bisou et boire des coups regarde
moi ça les amours monsieur bonjour bon
dieu veille que coûte quasiment tous les
jours monsieur tellement il est 14
heures 46 a toujours pensé qu'on les a
toujours pas danger on attendre mais on
mange quoi aum en juin avec modération
foie gras maison sautait d'autruche et
petites bûches maman je t'aime
bonjour
alors ils voudraient que je me mette en
feu le way ça va être bon en faire un
club sandwich bancaire est juif
nous avons richard gier mais robert
guerre jean michel jarre michel presque
isle il est beau comme un camion futur
complète moi à l'époque qui poussait les
cailloux et c'était mon pouce soyez mois
d'avril il rade et maintenant lotus le
pkk a changé grave et ils couchent
ensemble je crois qu'il est capable
moi j'adore les autruches
mais ce que j'aime par dessus tout c'est
les manger
c'est toi qui l'a chassé l'autruche on
se fait chier si tu veux on était un
point de la girouette est en fait elle
avait les cars qui était bien bien bien
bien été élevé comme ça j'étais ok jazz
bref c'est pas con avec tgv et l'âge des
shoots et mondial
bîmes est une autre garage en tout cas
c'est très beau mais ça c'est si pluie
joue les solides où je les regarde le
but aller manger au kac hausse est très
très bon il a oublié qu'elle était
légale
c'est le genre d'endroit tu vas pour
bouffer tu peux y rester deux jours deux
jours est toujours entier
on va voir quoi là comme film ou du mail
mais c'est pas la suite de dark vador
c'est dark vador contre attaque d'accord
ouais on est malin bon là on est parti
pour aller voir star wars engone
franchement ce qui paraît si une tuerie
donc j'espère qu'on va bien bien c'est
clair on fait la queue là il ya beaucoup
[Musique]
oh
e